all right where's alex where's alex t at
tanella what's up buddy clap it up for
alex
my name
we know alex uh from the live streams
he's a real [ __ ] dirtbag
i love you buddy
[Laughter]
somebody just say what
he has such a boston accent boston
doesn't understand
that that was perfectly quiet for that
what the [ __ ] is this guy talking about
what's up buddy how are you ma'am
fantastic uh he's throwing his voice
alex is also a ventriloquist yeah
his lawyer showed up
fantastic and he has no bench wide
it's like that [ __ ] from the way
just kidding buddy we love you
[Laughter]
just in case it was a murder
just in case it was a murder
that's in your bet
comes down here gets a little stabby
[Laughter]
all right alex's question is
because of road rage have you ever
beeped the horn as a passenger
my [ __ ] man that's a [ __ ] home run
right there
that is northeast anger at its finest
his mom's in there like what the [ __ ]
alex
ah drivers don't like that [ __ ] when you
do that that stands on me oh what the
[ __ ] are you doing
you get me shot
that is trash
late to court what are you gonna
do got to get there
you don't want to benchy out on you
a benchy
not even the [ __ ] departed shut up
you don't want a benchy kid